[Música]
yo quiero hoy hacerles una invitación
tengo a invitarlos a que cambien el
mundo
quizás es una invitación arriesgada
utópica radical sí desde luego pero yo
no entiendo la educación de otra forma
la educación para mí es transformación
la educación no puede ser permanencia la
educación es cambio y
bueno desde ese punto de vista vamos a
a cambiar el mundo el mundo realmente
está cambiando o hay que cambiarlo la
verdad es que el mundo está cambiando lo
queramos o no y está cambiando en un
sentido que a veces no podemos imaginar
la educación tiene que ir a la par de
ese cambio aliento flare el visionario
del siglo pasado ya hace algunos años
decía que
los analfabetas de este siglo 21 no iban
a ser aquellos que no pudieran leer o
escribir sino aquellos que no fueran
capaces de aprender desaprender y re
aprender
de esta manera nos plantea que cada vez
los cambios son más constantes y cada
vez tenemos que adaptarnos y aprender
cosas nuevas estamos definitivamente
ante una generación
de alumnos que son totalmente distintos
a nosotros profesores que son totalmente
distintos a cuando nosotros éramos
alumnos a su vez que tan distintos bueno
radicalmente diferentes hay una
organización que cada año se dedica a
hacer una lista de cómo van a ser los
que este año ingresen a la universidad
la última que hicieron fue la de los que
van a ingresar los que ingresaron el año
pasado y que se gradúan dentro de tres o
cuatro años esos jóvenes que ya están en
la universidad que en muy poco tiempo
van a ser licenciados que van a ser
ingenieros son radicalmente diferentes
de la mayoría de los adultos que ya
estamos en este mundo
algunos ejemplos
para estos jóvenes es inconcebible que
hubo un tiempo en que había anuncios de
cigarros
toda su vida la han vivido sin anuncios
de cigarros
no pueden concebir que era un
es un ejemplo verdad el hombre marlboro
y que había gente que tenía esa
intención de parecerse a esos vaqueros
no pueden concebir que antes los boletos
de avión tenían que irse a comprar
físicamente en las aerolíneas no existía
por supuesto de internet y ahorita todos
los boletos pueden comprarse en línea
se les hace impensable y hubo un momento
en que en ese viaje en el en el
aeropuerto tuviéramos que cargar las
maletas en lugar de simplemente rodar
las
y bueno muchos los más
esto que nos lleva a que esta generación
piensa o no se aprende de una manera
totalmente diferente a como lo hicimos
nosotros entonces al educador que está
frente a estos muchachos a este delante
estos niños o adolescentes
sedes plantea el reto de educarlos para
la vida para un mundo para que sean
exitosos
pero antes quizás esta labor ésta era un
poquito más sencilla
porque lo que nosotros aprendíamos podía
aplicarse y seguir aplicándose diez
quince veinte años más actualmente
estos muchachos se van a enfrentar a un
mundo
que no existe no lo conocemos siquiera
como vamos a educarlos para un mundo que
no sabemos cómo va a ser
bueno pues ahí está uno de los grandes
retos de esa educación
volviendo al planteamiento original
cómo vamos a transformar el mundo pues
la respuesta nos la da una jovencita que
a sus 17 años ganó el premio nobel de la
paz- y ya nos decía que maestro
un alumno un cuaderno y una pluma pueden
cambiar el mundo la educación realmente
puede transformar el mundo un maestro
que es capaz de tocar una vida de formar
una vocación de hacer un antes y un
después desde luego que va a ser la
diferencia al menos en un alumno si ese
maestro es capaz de tocar
25 30 alumnos en su año escolar
al pasar
30 años de servicio les habrá tocado el
corazón cambió la vida de 750 800
alumnos y si ese maestro además se
dedica a formar maestros esto se hace
exponencial y un solo maestro que pase
su vida dedicando a formar a otros a lo
largo de 25 ó 30 años de servicio habrá
cambiado la vida de más de medio millón
de personas
no es poca cosa en ninguna comunidad
menos en una comunidad como la nuestra
qué diferencia habría
en una comunidad como chihuahua si medio
millón de personas fueran distintas
distintas para bien por supuesto
dice sugata mitra que si hay un maestro
que puede ser sustituido por una
computadora ese maestro debe ser
cambiado porque el papel de un maestro
no es dar información si es que alguna
vez lo fue
pero hoy menos que nunca el papel de un
maestro no es dar información
porque una computadora con internet un
teléfono celular no va a ser mejor más
rápido más eficiente
la labor del maestro no es dar las
respuestas la labor de un maestro es
proponer las preguntas las preguntas que
sean capaces de dirigir una vida de
crear una pasión de formar vocaciones
esas preguntas que van a hacer que el
alumno por sí mismo logre sus objetivos
alcance sus sueños conozca cuáles son
sus sueños y pueda llegar a donde él
quiera
de esta manera yo les dejo la invitación
si son ustedes maestros que sean ese
maestro que es la diferencia que sean
ese maestro que toca vidas cambia la
percepción de sus alumnos
independientemente del campo formativo
en el que trabajen independientemente de
contenidos académicos sean ese maestro
que cambia vidas y estarán cambiando al
mundo
[Aplausos]
[Música]